this entire curry comes together in one
pot and what's not to love about that
hi I'm con Shawn we're gonna make an
easy yet delicious chicken curry people
feel like to enjoy spices they have to
cook a curry or a very involved recipe
instead of plain rice I love adding a
touch of spice to rice with cinnamon and
cardamom they add flavor and a wonderful
aroma if we remove the cardamom before
we serve the rice I mean if you're
hardcore you can bite into it it's very
peppery minty and almost floral it's
really amazing but I have bitten into
one as a kid and I was like what is that
growing up in India I ate this chicken
curry all the time at my grandma's house
I wanted to create a chicken curry
without compromising on flavor or
texture or any of that to make it more
approachable for a busy home cook who
wants to whip this up on a weeknight as
dinner for the whole family so there's
just a host of spices to still give you
that complexity but I might omit the
cayenne pepper for my kids I'm always
thinking about a few things when I'm
feeding my family I want to raise
adventurous eaters so I'm always
thinking how can I pack flavor how can I
expand their palates exposure is key
when it comes to kids they say it takes
exposures to a food and a visual
exposure counts so even putting it on a
plate if it doesn't get touched is an
exposure so just keep exposing them and
keep celebrating and they will catch on
I'm also trying to nourish them so how
can I make this healthy and nutritious I
did my PhD in biomedical sciences at
Harvard Medical School and my lab
started to study spices in cancer and
that got me really thinking about how
all this ancient wisdom around spices is
now being validated by modern medicine
so one of the reasons I love this
chicken curry is because it incorporates
so many flavor packed and beneficial
spices the turmeric the cumin the
coriander all of these boosts digestion
they also have anti-inflammatory
properties they are anti oxidants is
really a host of benefit so the fact
that I can put on the table this
delicious curry that's also packed with
benefits and color and flavor is just a
really rewarding and fulfilling
experience for me
oh yes
you